hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
just checking see you know you've just
seen are you weeks going you know you're
almost there
especially now late this [__] podcast
is I apologize I had an early call today
early call today had to do a scene
walking around in my underwear no jeez
it's just a movie clear the set here
comes old freckled balls had a good time
then I came in on with Bobby Kelly I did
ricky gervais says podcast I did Bobby
Kelley's podcast from [__] up in the
shed I did that I'm just knocking out
podcasts right and left huh you think
you think old freckleface was gonna book
a movie and and and he wasn't gonna stay
noticeable in the podcast whatever you
kids saying [__] Instagram by the way
I ever I have an account you guys gotta
follow this guy is [__] hilarious on
Instagram he gets footage of fights and
then he does the commentating on it and
this guy is [__] hilarious hang on a
second here I just sent it to somebody
one of them is this naked asian dude
[__] fighting here post is
unavailable because it was deleted oh
Jesus well I guess that account came and
went wait a second all right here we go
here we go it's called crime phases
providing best Street commentary putting
a face and a voice to current events and
Street follow us that [__] whoever it
is really really really funny they had
to delete this one because I swear to
god it was it was a it was these two
Asian dudes and two black dudes and I
don't know what the [__] went down this
guy tried to say it was over some sort
of food I can't make it funny the way he
did but one of the guys for whatever
reason was completely naked
and the black dude knocks out the other
dude first and for some reason leaves
the naked dude now you'd think you'd
want to do the naked guy first BAM knock
him out just so you know not to [__]
deal with the naked guy but he doesn't
and then the naked guy squares off like
he's wearing clothes
you know if you ever wondered what you
junk did while you were in a street
fight
all the answers are all the questions
are answered in this video but this guy
I don't know what happened some [__]
[__] flagged it yeah you know I
understand I weighed his dick out then
yeah but you should watch it they got
he's got you know all kinds of like just
[__] hilarious commentary beyond the
obvious oh [__] this guy really like
it's you know a lot of layers to a big
fan big fan of that wants to check it
out I'd like to do that every once in a
while just say shout out to fire you
guys have some cool Instagram things to
follow one person did watch the video
just those puke emojis look at me 2019
I'm Instagram shouting out I'm talking
about emojis Jesus Christ I'm ready to
go to a [__] college undercover right
like Jonathan Cryer hiding out I'm in my
50s so you know at this point if a guy
in his 30s can [__] pretend to be a
high school guy stood it right I guess a
guy in his 50s can pretend he said
[__] grad student this summer bill
burr is hiding out anyway we are here in
New York City there is a heat wave
everybody I got caught in this
ridiculous downpour and I was going down
to the fat black pussycat
but whatever how are you supposed to say
that politically correct right the
plus-sized african-american feline
gender neutral feline and I was just
doing like 15 minutes in front of him
and I walked out of my apartment and I
was like I think it's gonna really
[__] rain I bought a raincoat just
for this occasion
because I don't like the umbrella
umbrella is is [__] it's basically
if there was no wind whatsoever I've
talked about this if it coming straight
down you're fine okay and if you're not
walking you're fine but the second you
start moving everything from the bottom
of your nose down is gonna get soaking
wet
I think the umbrella is just so you can
see through the rain it's not really to
not make you [__] wet so I bought
this [__] raincoat but the rain coat
is like it's no joke you know being that
it's waterproof it holds in your body
heat and it was humid as hell so it's
like I'm gonna walk around on this thing
like some fighter trying to cut weight
before a [__] match and if it doesn't
rain I'm gonna have to lug this thing
around so I was like a half [__] it I'm
all right right so what do I do I jump
on the [__] train I go downtown I'm
listening to my music I'm having a good
time
right I come up out of the cellar out of
the cellar out of the [__] subway to
go to the cellar I'm all the way over on
Christopher Street right and because I
want to check out that famous cigar
store see what they had in there and I
[__] go out there and it's like as I
go through the turnstiles it's just a
bunch of people gathered staring up the
stairs so that means one of two things
okay either somebody really fat or
physically [__] up is coming down the
stairs there's a fight something [__]
up or it's raining so now that I'm back
in New York mode
I'm hoping it's one of the previous
things selfishly selfishly New York
makes you very selfish you're all about
the gay pride parade until you're stuck
in it and then you just like [__] these
people right [__] these happy people and
trying to get where I'm going
so it was like it was rain and angry so
I ran into this [__] drugstore and
the guy sitting there like a you want
this three dollar umbrella for five
dollars it's like what the [__] am I
gonna do go out there and get soaking
wet it'd be late it was raining like we
were out in the rain for three seconds
and was you might as well just jump in
somebody's [__] pool and that was not
going onstage with wet underwear
[__] you know that happens you walk
around your pants will dry off but your
undergarments uh they just remind you
they won't let the pass go will they you
know so it's like a secret you caught in
the rain no I wasn't right and then you
[__] underwear pops up in me to show
about the [__] weather you were in
I'd like to apologize to all the briefs
I continued to wear out of my under my
pants after that rain fall if I hurt any
underwear during that last rainstorm I I
did lead to I'm coming out of the closet
if that helps um anyway Jesus remind me
what about that [__] I didn't even
pay attention that guy that [__]
billionaire pedophile with his own
[__] Island that sounds like a cheesy
b-movie I can't believe that was
actually real this guy doesn't even gets
put in [__] jail
[__] time and spends 12 hours a day
in his own [__] mansion that's unreal
you know if I ran jails by the way as
much as I'm into punishing people I
would stop short of no [__] that's
where I would draw the line okay you
want to incarcerate somebody but blah
blah blah and all that type of [__] but
you know there's clearly plenty of women
out there that really are into guys that
are into jail so why not bring them in
once there once a day you haven't come
in there you [__] them you keep
everybody relaxed and then that's then
you're you fine no more riots no more
raping [__] you know some accountant
whose wife asks for too much [__]
alimony and he snapped and he grabs
something that they got together at the
Epcot Center that used that used to
represent their love and now represents
their divide and he decided to smash it
then he accidentally killed her and he
feels bad and he wouldn't kill anybody
else he's not a killer it was just a
passionate a moment of passion he's not
gonna kill anybody else unless he gets
married again and she asked for too much
money during the divorce settlement
right he's that kind of a killer
okay he's like the killing he's the
murdering equivalent of that guy who his
team is down 17 to eight two outs down
to the last strike and he's still
sitting there keeping score in the
[__] Sun when everybody else left
passion anyways you know so then that
guy goes to jail and now he's getting
raped [__] seven ways to Sunday they
just you know if you just [__] went
out there you got those [__] lunatics
a little bit of ass a couple times a
week what why does it have to be
straight across the board punishment you
keeping people calm you're making the
judge the the the [__] the the guys
who worked there what he called now the
assistants the Matadors what do you call
the [__] people with the guards Jesus
Christ I can't even think today the
Matadors yeah you making their job easy
everybody's getting laid everybody's
[__] fine you know be the easiest
more than ever
second there was a riot I just be on the
bullhorn like that yeah what exactly is
the problem the society please explain
to me what the problem is a free room
and board and you're getting [__] six
times a week that's right it is a good
deal all right we'll put down the
sharpened toothbrush I love you thank
you and then they go back to their cells
it's write the words a good guy I know
you're supposed to punish people but you
know what I mean you're also you know
getting everybody all [__] pent up I
mean I know they've made a whole [__]
channel out of it well not now you know
you can't turn that you can't turn it
back cuz they got the eyeball they
literally have a whole [__] network
they one of those channels is
essentially the prison right channel
right behind the bar saying Quinton they
do all that [__] what the tattoos mean
over here is the Latino section over
here is the white section so he's always
neo-nazis right over here's the black
section
everybody's gotta [__] explain stuff
see is a white guy I'm not allowed to go
yeah I would assume that they'll be
honest with yourself as a white suburban
guy like myself how big of a [__]
Nazi would you become the second you
join you got into prison you yet you
just have to do it in order to survive
I mean how progressive are you that
you're gonna take a gang raping in your
ass you know I mean would you rather do
that or just [__] just you know just
kind of go hey you know white power you
know with the same enthusiasm you do
when someone does the wave when you go
to a baseball game and someone gets the
wave going and you just [__] sick of
it thirty years of doing it but you know
if you're with somebody bring your
nephew there hey you forget white power
white power I don't wanna get raped
god bless Hitler keep your dick out of
my ass you know whatever that body
language looks likes I'm sure there's
some psychiatrists out there they can
tell you what that looks like all right
Jesus Christ how did we get here well
this is how you get here you don't have
a guest he you start talking to yourself
and then all of a sudden things just
open up anyway uh better on a big Bill
Withers kick man I [__] can't get
enough of that guy and not his hits I
like his albums I like his albums and
James Gatson is is quickly becoming one
of my favorite drummers becoming one of
my top-five drummers of all time you
know what's crazy I saw he was actually
still out there playing in LA he did
some gig I got to catch him next time he
plays cuz I think he's like 80 81 years
old absolutely [__] incredible
incredible drummer I was actually
hanging with Bobby after his podcast and
we were messing around on his drums and
he was going who you listening to now
something like that and I played it to
him I was saying listen how good that
sound and I literally listening to it I
go look at look at my arm and my hair
was standing up case gives me chills how
good that guy [__] place so check him
out if you get a chance and if you're
gonna listen to Bill Withers I've just
downloadin don't get the greatest hits
he's not a greatest hits guy he's a Iza
album guy some bands you don't need you
know they have the couple hits each
album and the rest of its a bunch you
know filler right I'll killer no filler
man remember that [__] bill weathers is
all killer no filler all right so have
it that I have a good time enjoy
yourselves all right seedling me I'm
done fixing the prison system
I'm telling you explaining you and in a
very like protecting myself way how I
would become a neo-nazi and you know
Instagram comp some good music I mean
why do you listen to other podcasts I
basically have done everything except
buy you a [__] lunch at this point
now this sucks man I got to make a
[__] phone call here and I'm flowing
today baby it's coming the ideas are
coming on let's just try to see how much
more I can do here before I get out of
here and then I'll have to [__] edit
this thing the thing I hate doing the
most anyways oh by the way the big gay
NBA Summer honey it's continuing Pride
Month is over but the big gay NBA Summer
is continuing I don't know where I left
you off but since we last talked Kawhi
Leonard is going to be sharing a home
with LeBron James but different bedrooms
and Chris Paul is going to Oklahoma
because evidently from what I heard
nobody likes them but you know what I
say do you Chris Paul yeah the NBA
offseason is the dumbest [__] I've ever
[__] it's not basketball season and
all of these [__] guys just they're
all coupling up with each other
everybody's pairing off trying to pile
on a [__] team nobody wants to
compete anymore I guess they got it
that's the way they got to compete it
just [__] just disgust me you know
and Larry Bird and Magic Johnson [__]
did that converse allstar commercial
back in the day they finally became
friends
but they didn't join Blair II didn't
join the Lakers he still wanted to
[__] beat his ass twice a year in the
regular season and then four out of
seven come June I don't know the NBA
lost me a long time ago last [__] ten
years ago I said it was fixed
everybody said I had a tinfoil hat on
because I was saying a bunch of other
crazy [__] at that point so you know in
defense of them I was a little nuts but
I was right about the NBA and they found
that [__] mobbed-up ref and then when
I set out what did I say everybody goes
all it's just that one guy oh is it is
it just that one guy isn't it always
just that one guy no matter what the
[__] happens it's just that one guy arms
for hostages Ollie north it was that one
guy sometimes you got to watch their
Zapruder film this [__] bullets
flying all over the place you know a guy
in the front seat even threw a couple of
jabs at JFK and all of a sudden it's
just this one [__] guy who was at the
movies who then it conveniently gets get
the [__] out of here didn't you guys
ever watch that Oliver Stone movie get
your facts straight man money what I'm
talking about here uh yeah I just don't
like this [__] I wanted to see the
Oklahoma City Thunder play the Golden
State Warriors I wanted to see the
rematch I want to see them try to avenge
blowing a three to one lead I didn't
want to see that one of the top [__]
guys just say [__] it I guess I'll just
join the Golden State Warriors
you know Jesus [__] Christ I blame the
Los Angeles Lakers they started this
[__] those [__] [__] trying to
buy a goddamn title now every every
[__] year it's just like the New York
Yankees and then everybody had to become
the Yankees if you wanted to [__]
compete and then what kills me what
kills me is the Yankees now are going
Oprah acting like they didn't do those
those didn't do it now of a sudden
they're all [__] high and mighty
trying to build out of their farm system
like everybody forgets their earlier
shows like The Oprah Winfrey Show when
she first came out when she had the
midgets running around chasing the
mailman who wanted to [__] their [__]
Nate but neighbor's wife or something
she did all of that [__] right
and then that one guest killed the other
guests on that other show and then she
walked away like she was never a part of
it
just stepped off you know like when Bugs
Bunny would be falling in some [__]
right and right before he hit the
[__] ground he would just step off it
he'd [__] did the other thing would
crash that's why he sucked it [__]
physics science classes watching too
many goddamn cartoons they justified all
of this [__] you know it's funny as I
still don't quite understand how an
explosion kills you like unless it just
blows you up like the how the shockwaves
how we can move air so [__] fast that
when it hits you it hits you so I guess
you go flying through the air so that
should be enough but I guess because
it's invisible it's look if a car hit a
guy and he flew across the parking lot
and he died I'd understand I just don't
get how air can be as hard as a [__]
car and explode your insights it's kind
of like water somebody jumps off to San
Francisco Bridge it's like how did he
die did he miss the water he hit the
water you get high enough it starts it
becomes like cement you know no I don't
I've never been that high highest I've
been is a [__] diving board so I
don't have any frame of reference when
it comes to suicide by water alright I
gotta make this [__] phone call and
of course I don't have the goddamn
number are they gonna call me are you
gonna call me where is it
[__] me this happens to me every time I
have a conference call are they calling
me
of course I wait till five twenty nine
when I have to do it if it [__] five
thirty do you guys want to listen in you
want to listen in on a on a conference
call about about a [__] stand-up
special
well too [__] bad kid I wouldn't do
that to be [__] weird
alright well until somebody [__]
tells me what the hell were they who the
hell I'm supposed to call and when do I
better not be a Skype if it's a Skype
I'm not gonna make it cuz I'm never
gonna be able to figure it out you like
that you like the lack of confidence I
have and the hell is it here is my
calendar date the 18th 5:30 Netflix call
did I put anything else in there [__]
off no context no number no nothing I'm
sure these stupid headphones are off
alright so anyway so I guess Chris Paul
is now in Oklahoma their point guard
just rejoined the the guy with the
beautiful beard James Harden James
Harden and so-and-so are together again
in Houston honey it's like When Harry
Met Sally
all those years they're finally getting
back together I can't even keep up with
it it's so [__] stupid
but it's genius on the NBA part because
look at me I think it's stupid and I'm
still [__] talking about it alright
it's now 531 if I don't get on the phone
soon enough does that mean I lose my
special I don't understand what the [__]
happens here alright but if I'm just
gonna get back to the goddamn podcast
shall I shall I well you know what
there's a heat wave out here heat wave
heat wave I got tonight that still is
shaking me up just that feeling of
[__] lawlessness that immediately
happened the second the power went out
you know so anyways this is [__] heat
wave here right so what does everybody
do everybody's gonna crank up their air
conditions and just add to the global
warming you know the word the [__]
thing about global warming it's the only
way that we're gonna fix it is if we get
comfortable oh there it is
we forget uncomfortable all right I'll
pick
that's not in a minute alright anyways
picking up where I left off there you go
just like that through the magic of
editing I just took a conference call
over at Netflix and guess what guess
what they're very excited about my new
special and you know what I've been in
this business long enough where I can
tell the difference between phony
excitement phone and intense excitement
and a real excitement so they are and so
am i I I can't wait for this thing to
come out so we were just discussing
strategies what's the best way to get it
out there with all the eyeballs the way
people consume products these days
played some assets that was all that
type of [__] and like Netflix they
always end up blowing you [__] mind
with the algorithms and all this stuff
that they come up with so I was
listening to that for like the last half
an hour and I am very optimistic I'm
gonna go to the usual places and then
some new places to try to expand my
comedic borders anyway so I was talking
about global warming though wasn't I
once again I already solved the
aggression problem in in our prison
systems because obviously the fear of
getting raped in the ass is not stopping
people from [__] committing crimes so
they're gonna do that anyways anything
gonna get raped in the ass and then
they're not going to be happy you know
or they gonna rape somebody in the ass
and that they have crossed that line
which will make them even worse person
and who's gonna pay for this in the end
it's going to be the guards right and
consider it most the president seen the
end of getting back out on the [__]
streets you know why don't you [__]
some of these [__] women you know
they want to [__] hook up with these
guys they're writing letters and [__]
bring them every and every once a while
some of these ladies out there they need
a little prison car right there you go
soft bring the testosterone down service
these ladies out here in the general
public where we're free law-abiding dick
is just not getting the job done
these ladies they they want to feel a
little danger alright they want to feel
a little danger in a controlled
environment just excellent the getting
made [__] on a leash you know you know
when a [__] dog runs to the end of
the leash back in the day I read his
[__] legs would swing out you let the
lunatic just runs into chick and you
only his body can't [__] make it
right well I guess his arms could unless
he's got a [__] monster dick that'd
be longer than all right so there's
things that need okay your tie is
[__] it's [__] ours mind his back
right he's got on a colored leash and
it's like alright there's a bunch of
women down there you run down there you
get to the end of the [__] thing you
got to have a [__] hard-on and go and
then he [__] runs down the other
thing with his [__] arms tied behind
his back he gets to the end
all right then any chick that likes him
just backs into his dick that's it you
just put him in like a dick stockade
like instead of your hands and your
[__] head it's your dick and your
Bulls there and he just stinks
he just stands in that [__] thing
he gets serviced then that's it it's
[__] over everybody's tested
everything's [__] fine everybody's
chilling out there you go or just do a
[__] glory hole glory hole all these
[__] unemployed people okay you know
what most of them have them coming they
have hands right so you get them you get
them some gloves to get in there and
they just [__] crank out you do it
you do it like whatever like you [__]
I don't know like your uh you know
Caddyshack polishing a [__] golf ball
jerk off a couple of [__] people and
keep the president safe I don't know I
don't know I don't know how to [__]
work all of this out I'm just saying
there's got to be a way to do it right
make people less fun you know it's
really weird you know when you pitch
ideas to yourself cuz you yourself is
just going yeah man this all makes sense
and then you just go to the next level
and then the next thing you know you
just talked yourself into a corner where
it's like that I just suggest that they
have glory holes and that [__]
unemployed people who never committed a
crime like their only option out of that
he's [__] to go jerk off a [__]
inmate through a hole I mean bill what
happened to your hole let's get these
[__] bankers that caused the 2008
thing let's go after these corporations
that have kept us in this never-ending
[__] war well we got plenty of
[__] money for that but for some
reason we won't help the firefighters
from 9/11 who are suffering have no
funding for that no [__] funding for
that give me a [__] break
[__] [__] lying pieces of [__]
it's a [__] land grab and you're
going after the natural resources you
know give a [__] about anybody else but
yourself and then if we question it
we're not American we're [__]
socialists and we should [__] leave
the country is that how it works there
we go now back on track I'm sorry about
all that [__] glory hole stuff I
don't know sometimes you know you start
talking you know and you you don't know
what you're gonna go anyway so let's do
a little advertising here
all right quip everybody all right the
truth is most of us are brushing our
teeth wrong not long enough and forget
to change our brush on time that's
because most brands focus on selling
flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing but not quit so what makes quip
so different next please mention all the
talking points below
hey quip if you [__] type it I'm
gonna read it alright first quip is an
electric toothbrush that's a fraction of
the cost of bulkier brushes while still
packing just the right amount of
vibration to help clean your teeth quips
built-in timer helps you clean that for
the dentist's recommended two minutes
with two minutes dentists recommend to
me you know what they're trying to do
they're trying to get you to brush away
your gums so they can do some
periodontal [__] work that's why you
got to get the quick brush because if
you do with the regular brush you're
going back and forth you know what I
mean with your hand holding onto the
[__] thing like the way the same
movement you would be doing in a glory
hole to help one of these prisoners out
god help them when they listen to this
[__] read
[Music]
you know what I'm saying that's why I
had to switch to an electric toothbrush
because I [__] I was starting to brush
my gums away you wouldn't know but this
is pro quit I'm all about this
alright the dentist recommended two
minutes with guiding pulses that remind
you when to switch sides ok next quips
quips you know what they should do to
remind you to switch sides they should
bring that [__] drill sergeant in
from Full Metal Jacket what side is this
pile right side sir
next quip subscription plans are for
your health not just convenience they
deliver new brush heads on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide quip also comes with
a mount that suctions right to your
mirror and unsticks to use as a cover
for hygienic travel wherever you take
your teeth and finally everyone loves
quip there they were on Oprah's o list
named one of Times best inventions and
is the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
Dental Association plus there they are
backed by a network of over 20,000
dentists and hygienists and hundreds of
thousands of happy brushes use quip
every single day quip starts at just 25
bucks and if you go to get quick calm
slash burn right now you'll get your
first refill pack with equip electronic
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
at get quip calm slash burrow spelled GE
t qu IP comm slash bur alright I think
I've done the required minutes thank you
to everybody that pre subscribed to get
a steve Gorman's new book hard to handle
the pre-order I'm telling you I've read
just I'm telling you I read just about
every rut biography out there
jaw-dropping jaw-dropping [__]
stories I had no idea no I do go to a
show you think everybody's getting along
you think everything's going you had no
[__] idea if you're not even if
you're not into music
you should read that [__] book it's
tremendous she can pre-order it I
tweeted the link it's in my thread
whatever they say definitely check that
out and this weekend I got a show in New
Jersey on Saturday night there's a few
tickets left Soul freckles stay shape
and as of tomorrow week seven out of ten
is over on the movie and next week next
week is the big week you know we
actually get to wear the firefighter
stuff we fight a fire as firefighters do
and we're already laughing known the day
that we decide to do it is gonna be the
hottest [__] day and so we're already
taking that son who's gonna [__] the
most who's gonna [__] pass out and
just make a complete [__] mockery of
what it means to be a fireman
so it should be a lot of fun all right
that's it everybody have a great weekend
you [__] and enjoy the music here and
then there's another half-hour of bonus
material here from an episode of
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast from a few years
ago from a couple weeks ago I don't know
how Andrew works it out but he does all
right
[Music]
Oh
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
July 18 2011 keep in mind that Jesus
Christ as Dodd for all so why is that
song in my head I still remember the guy
who sang it back when I was a lad and I
went to church oh Jesus I might tell you
guys that [__] I was actually an altar
boy I dressed up like a little angel and
I sat there and I rang the bells and I
what did I hold I held some sort of
something when people took communion I
hold that little gold spatula case I
don't know what the little wafer fell
out that represented the flesh of
another human being which if you really
look at it it's pretty [__]
disgusting this is the Monday morning
podcast and I'm taping this Sunday night
I'm recording this by myself in a hotel
room and a wonderful downtown San Jose I
just wrapped up my weekend at the San
Jose improv obviously it's not like I'd
be working the one in Houston if I was
LA you ever just hate yourself I just
really hated myself in that moment um
for even attempting to make that joke no
[__] you of all you are all your jokes
good huh it's just the Monday morning
every [__] joke is funny podcast I
never said that you got to have the bad
ones so it's so that you can compare
them to the good ones you wouldn't know
what a [__] good joke was if I didn't
tell such a bad joke there right so
stand down mister you all grumpy at me
because you forgot to crack your windows
and now you sitting there in your car
and your dashboard is all [__] hot
you're all heated up so now you giving
me [__] I don't need it buddy I don't
[__] need it
so anyways beautiful downtown San Jose
and it's a really lovely town it's a
very it's a town that really I don't
know there's a big-time mister
action with this town because it looks
like Maybury but you can get [__] up
at 10:00 in the morning in San Jose and
this is I'm just I don't have any
evidence of that that's just the vibe I
don't know what it is they've got all
these great stores all these great
restaurants they have a trolley okay
I'm a classic white guy nothing makes a
white guy feel safe like a trolley the
second we see a trolley I don't know we
start picturing butterflies and flowers
and a gazebo maybe you got a trolley
that's quaint you know how am I gonna
get [__] up in such a quaint
atmosphere well I don't know I don't
understand San Jose they have a [__]
homeless problem out here the likes of
which I haven't seen since the last time
I went to San Francisco which is oddly
right up the street maybe they took the
trolley over that really made me laugh I
hope you enjoyed it cuz I sure did
anyways anyway some of the I'll tell you
something right now
you know [__] San Francisco and San
Jose have some of the dirtiest most
filthiest [__] homeless people I've
ever seen in my life I was talking about
this on stage tonight I might as well
share it with you right I understand
you're homeless you live outside I
understand that you're gonna be dirty
but these [__] people it's like it's
like they walked out of the Dust Bowl I
don't think it doesn't seem possible to
be as dirty as these people it's like
dirt it's not grime from the city they
have like clay on their faith they look
like boxcar Willie like old school
homeless like it's like they walk
outside the city they find a bunch of
dirt is that my phone ringing that's
probably somebody telling me to shut the
[__] up I'm being too loved watch this
hello hey I'm doing the podcast I
thought you were the person in the next
room over telling me to shut up say
hello to the podcast listeners could you
guys hear that I couldn't even tell all
right let me let me call you when I'm
done with this [__] okay all right
buh-bye
I could have hit pause anyways what I
was talking about those dirty filthy ass
[__] homeless people it's like they
go outside the city they go into the
woods and they just roll around and dirt
and and they come back and they're
[__] a horrific looking but I had
such a great time here this I'm telling
you you got to come down if you're
anywhere near San Jose downtown San Jose
now that I've [__] all over it The
Improv it's at this beautiful old
theater I remember last time I was here
they were saying how old it was how
Charlie Chaplin used to perform there
and you know Buster Keaton and all these
guys so and of course it's haunted right
there were always haunted but no one can
ever get it on video so anyways I don't
know either just amazing crowd showed up
all week and I had a great [__] time
on it I gotta tell you this place creeps
me out you know I was I took a walk
there's this great new drum shop out
here
San Jose Pro drum shop I believe I went
down there and it was like a mile away
from my hotel so I decided alright I'm
kind of sick of working out Jesus look
at the [__] tits on her Wow Jesus
Christ who the [__] is that it's Kate
Upton who the [__] is Kate Upton channel
112 sorry I got the TV on in the
background what a [__] rack oh god
bless her Jesus Christ anyways oh let me
talk about what's on the TV here Planet
of the Apes the prequel is on it's
coming out it's coming out and [__] I
don't know in August and I was all
excited to see this goddamn movie
remember when I hyped it a few [__]
months ago and I'm saying how insane
this looks and I
I can't wait to see it and guaranteed it
was gonna be a blockbuster then I found
out was pg-13 and I was like you gotta
be a [__] how to [__] our Apes taken
over the world pg-13 can somebody
explain that to me I was saying that to
kneei god I don't want to see it now she
goes what do you mean you want to see it
I don't want to see it she goes why I
said cuz it's pg-13 she goes so why'd I
go it should be rated R she goes Jesus
Christ what do you want to see monkeys
[__] I butchered it I wish she'd set
it on the podcast it would have been the
line of the [__] week but can you
guys back me on that one I'm still gonna
go see it but that means like rather
than having like showing what a monkey
can do to you you saw it happen that way
she got a face ripped off they're not
gonna show that now because it's pg-13
they [__] alligator arm because they
want to try to get families to go out
and go see it can we make the Apes a
little less angry can we just
this is like the industry notes they
probably showed up with this awesome
rated our [__] script and then the
goddamn suits just butchered the [__]
out of it I'd like to say something I'd
like to contribute something even though
I don't have something to add I just
feel like this meetings gonna come to a
close and if I don't speak at this
moment there's no way for me to justify
my desk ah they've ruined it you [__]
[__] anyways I'm still gonna go see it
could somebody any listener out there
please explain to me how if Apes overran
the [__] world how the hell that
would be pg-13 even if they just showed
the footage on the news you would have
that guy going just to warn you this is
very graphic you cut it to a bunch of
people getting that [__] faces ripped
off pg-13 let me guess there's gonna be
one nice ape right it's gonna save James
Franco then they're gonna probably sing
a duet by the end of it that's a pg-13
movie you know have some [__] balls
pg-13 that's
that's [__] rated-r alright and if I
was ever elected okay if I was ever
elected that's one of the first things I
would do away with aside from hunting
down bankers I would have liked legal
you know they have like deer hunting
season I would have like banker you know
killing me to shoot him in the ass with
a BB gun to something some sort of a
push back on our side so anyways what
the [__] was I talking about here Oh San
Jose so I'm out here I'm having a great
time there's dirty filthy [__]
homeless people so I that's right let me
let me let me meander back to where the
hell where the hell I was about five
minutes ago so I'm on my way over to the
San Jose
drum shop and I see that it's like a
mile away alright so I'm not into
working out anymore I think it's [__]
stupid I'm into exercising staying
active stretching walk in that type of
[__] but sitting there lifting weights
of going on an elliptical for an hour
doesn't make any goddamn sense to me I
think in the short run it makes you look
good but all you're doing is wearing out
your joints you know if you quit eating
court upon it with cheese's you don't
have to [__] go on that thing
look at people back in the day I'll
goddamn skinny they were they didn't
have any ellipticals they they [__]
ran around outside with that dog till it
got rabies and then they stuck in an
outhouse and eventually they made the
oldest kid shoot it for some [__]
reason that's what they did they didn't
sit around eating cookies the size of
your face so anyways I'm like this
shit's only like I don't like a mile
away so I'll walk over there I'll see
what they got and then then I'll walk
back that'll be a two mile walk and then
I'll go get a salad like a fan and
that'll be my day I'll be alright
so I walk over there I don't have any
problems alright have a great time
[__] drum shop is beautiful all kinds
of people over there helping me out I
had a great [__] time bought some
drum sticks and I left
and on the way back I'm on the phone I'm
making some calls and making some moves
cuz I'm a player right
I'm calling whatever I'm talking to some
[__] person trying to figure out why
I didn't have more media here in San
Jose that's basically what I'm doing and
as I'm walking down the street all of a
sudden I see this [__] lay walking
towards me alright
she didn't look like she was on meth but
she didn't look like she wasn't on meth
she didn't look like a hooker but she
didn't look like you know maybe she
didn't suck a dick every once in a while
for 20 bucks she's one of those maybe
people right so immediately my inner
sort of defense system kicked in the
first thing when you look at somebody
crazy you kind of look to see if they
have a weapon and once you see that they
don't you then kind of maybe glance
around see if they have a partner right
no partner coast is clear and then
that's the last thing you got to worry
about don't get scratched so I'm walking
and she's [__] diagonally coming
towards me as I'm on the phone she's
gonna excuse me share why she let me
know he do it correctly with the audio
she's far away walking towards me excuse
me excuse me sure and I just keep
walking right by as your excuse me
excuse me sure and I walk right by her
you know just blow her off I just keep
[__] walking trying to figure out why
I didn't have enough radio to sell more
tickets here in San Jose and then all
Sun she yells at me you can at least
acknowledge me which of course kicked
into my temper and I immediately turned
around I was like I'm on the [__]
phone right which immediately struck me
is funny because that used to be that
conversation used to only happen indoors
that was like an indoor conversation but
now because of Technology the fact that
I was staying walking on a sidewalk
under a [__] overpass I can actually
scream I'm on the phone and it felt like
oddly intimate like I had a relationship
with this person you know it really
pissed me off was at that point when she
got me to flip out she completely
ignored me so
now I wanted to be acknowledged and she
totally turned the tables on me which I
gotta tell you is one of the easiest
things to do is turn the tables on
somebody who has a [__] temper that's
happened to me my entire goddamn life
and I'm in a very torturous part of my
life where you know back in the day I
didn't realize that that's what was
happening so I had that ignorant his
bliss moment but now it's a torturous
time because I am completely aware of
what a [__] fool I am so if you're
listening to this lady congratulations
to you you won that round oh and
speaking of ladies how about the World
Cup women's final did anybody watch that
it was [__] devastating as a fan of
u.s. women's soccer that I became when I
found out that they were in the finals I
got to tell you I went down to a sports
bar and I had an unbelievable time
watching that game it was a [__]
awesome game whose heartbreaking and
that type of [__] to see them lose it
and a lot of hotties on the team too a
lot of [__] good-looking girls a
little thick thighs and they're [__]
tanned up legs you know was hoping they
were gonna win it
but was it meant to be and
congratulations to the women's soccer
team from Japan you guys play an awesome
game you never said die he came back and
I got to tell you that [__] corner
kick when they scored that second goal
how do you defend against that that was
[__] insane insane goal and you know
whatever
obviously I'm rooting for the u.s.
ladies but uh it was good if anybody was
gonna win it it was good for Japan all
the [__] that they've been through this
year so now that I've patted him on the
back I have to ask the Japanese people a
question what the [__] was with all
those Teen Wolf haircuts all the women
had on your team can you explain those
[__] haircut like five of them I
swear to God every time I saw it from
behind I thought it was Michael J Fox
unfuckin
believable genre there's no excuse for
it either back in the day you know if
you lived in the middle of nowhere or
you lived on the other side of the world
and you weren't up on what the style was
I could see you having a Teen Wolf
haircut and not realizing that the last
person to have that haircut was I think
maybe Dennis Miller on one of the last
episodes he kind of got away with rockin
the mullet for a long [__] time that
guy but now there's the Internet there's
really no excuse wasn't all the ladies
on the team but there was like five of
them I was like what the [__] I don't
know what was I supposed to do just a
hundred percent congratulate him go [__]
yourselves everybody gets [__] on this
goddamn podcast as did I somebody gave
me [__] on Twitter said they came out to
see my show so I saw Bill burr at The
Improv and it was one hour of the exact
same joke I somehow missed the funny
part and I gotta tell you that one
really stung you know why because I
think she was right I just [__] went
off on this goddamn tirade I don't know
what's where my act is right now it's
just like I've come to the end of
trashing women I'm just sick of doing it
and my I have one show where I just
started on this [__] trash and woman
thing and I don't think I pulled up the
entire [__] show I'm sure a lot of
guys liked it but I could really see
actually tonight I think I had one of my
most balanced shows of the weekend
because of that woman's criticism she
was I think she was 100% right because I
kind of thought back to my act I was
like well for the first three minutes
I wasn't trashing women and then for the
next hour and twelve ie I think I was
guilty as charged everybody oh so
anyways speaking of sports did anybody
watch the ESPYs last week anybody
watched those or watched him on
Wednesday me and Paul virzi my my friend
outside of this business and within the
business he opens for me on a lot of
East Coast dates right out to about
Minnesota they can suffer
DeRosa what if [__] a furthest west
I've gone with him I would give us a
[__] let's plow ahead did we actually
submitted some jokes we was sitting
there going you know we're always joking
around about sports Roy's breaking each
other's balls
I had an in I knew somebody who knew
somebody who knew somebody who knew Seth
and I said [__] it let's submit some
jokes we actually got a couple on I was
psyched and then I ended up getting some
tickets me and Nia went down I went to
the ESPYs everybody like a [__] big
shot you know it's funny I actually got
to walk the red carpet and there's all
these giant [__] and it was awesome
it was and walking a red carpet is as
awesome as you would think it is and
except when no one knows who the [__]
you are then you feel like an [__]
you know [__] walking like Dirk
Nowitzki's standing there just won a
[__] NBA championship and I'm like
I'm playing the San Jose improv next
week if anybody cares I tried to make an
excuse that the reason I didn't hang out
was because it was too sunny and then
hang out cuz nobody knew where the [__]
I was if they knew who I was I would
have sat stand and they're running my
[__] yep but anyway so we ended up
going inside right you know was awesome
I don't I don't bug people for pictures
you know I just I don't do that [__] but
there were doctor [__] J dr. J was
sitting about five rows down and I was
in the middle and it was like 20 people
to the right 20 people to the left of me
and he was sitting right on the aisle
because you know he's got long legs and
also they want to cut to him when
they're shooting people and he was
standing there and like a bunch of
[__] nerdy white guys like me were
walking up and he was shaking their
hands and getting that picture and I'm
just sitting there going that's dr. J I
gotta do it I gotta [__] do you
kidding me that guy he like this
tire Oh ESPN is standing on his
shoulders this is the original guy
the original winner of the [__]
dunking contest the original guy who
took the game above the rim the best
[__] afro the guy who saved the ABA
that caused the ABA to combine with the
NBA the best [__] nickname those
Celtics 76ers series of the early 80s
some of the best basketball I ever saw
julius jams jinx
remember that cover of Sports
Illustrated when they got by the Celtics
that [__] 1983 team fo fo-fo I gotta
get a picture with this guy when I
finally said [__] this I'm doing it
right as I stand up Heath the
announcement was attention please
everybody showed up your cell phones the
award show is gonna be getting just a
minute and then he sits down I was like
[__] all right [__] this I'm gonna get
it I'm gonna get a shot I'll get a
picture with them at the end of it right
and then all of a sudden the show starts
Seth Meyers comes out and now I'm
sitting there all nervous going [__] is
it because I had a feeling you know that
maybe we were going to get a couple on
and he ended up doing two jokes and
thank God they both did well and I don't
know man I was I was a rush
stephannie [__] rush I was always
wondering if I could write for somebody
else first of all if I could do it and
then secondly how I would would I be
bummed is an egomaniac comedian that I
didn't tell the joke would it uh would
it bother me and it didn't I actually I
got like a different sort of thrill out
of it I was so [__] nervous I was
like oh my god what if I write him
something and he says it and it bombs
you know and then he's up there looking
like a jerk off because of me you know
what I mean that's like accidentally
shooting somebody in your own platoon
and you got a [__] to live with that
you know so thank God they did well and
and I was able to relax and enjoy the
rest of the show
and and then the end of the show comes
on Mike alright I'm gonna get this
picture with dr. J and there's like 20
[__] people to get to that I have to
try and step over they all stand up at
the same time and you know he's dr. J so
he just gets assured out and I keep
thinking that I can somehow zigzag
through people and I just see his
[__] silver afro it's not an afro
it's cut down you know short now when
he's like six six or whatever I just
watched him slowly disappearing into the
crowd and then it was full he was over I
didn't get the goddamn picture I didn't
seize the day but uh but I ended up
being a great night and you know I don't
know being virzi with like two little
girls all excited that we actually got
something on there so uh so there you go
there's a happy story how about that
every week I'm always [__] angry on
this goddamn thing and um you know look
at that that wasn't actually that was
that what I I believe that that might
have been the first feel-good story that
I've ever told in the podcast how did
that feel did it make you feel
uncomfortable all right well let's get
back to trashing people then how about
that here's something for you like I
don't know what all the fascination is
with redheads are lately I don't know if
it's because South Park did that kick a
ginger day but like I've never felt like
more of a freak in my life there's just
all this [__] coming out you know I
didn't somebody sent me an article it
says do redheads need extra anesthesia
and evidently it said it goes it's bad
enough that redheads and then they go or
gingers as our British friends call them
since when have they been our friends
you should just say or gingers because
South Park made that [__] mainstream
you know give credit where credit's due
all right actually you know I kind of
like that they actually say that that's
a British word because I always get
weirded out when people say that because
it sounds like you're like auditioning
for lock stock and to [__] barrels
whatever the hell the name of that movie
is because I've always known that word
over there and to hear [__] people in
like Indiana use that you know
considering
never been to Europe it always strikes
me as funny you know I gotta know where
they just like oh yeah top of the mornin
to you so anyways it's it's bad enough
that redheads may one day be extinct you
know what a way to start it right off
the bat evidently we're like dying out
ah jeez if you mentioned being the last
one on earth oh I thought I had a bad
childhood holy [__] now we find out that
people with red hair need more
anesthesia than other people do okay
what the [__] you like I don't already
feel like enough of a freak I get it
I don't look like other people I'm one
step away like albinos don't get as much
[__] as redheads do Bert lately alright
a 2002 study conducted by researchers at
the University of Louisville Kentucky
and I guarantee you nobody from Kentucky
was doing that research that's all
people from smart states they couldn't
get a job at other schools and then they
go to Louisville there's not one smart
person in Kentucky I guarantee you how
[__] relax I'm giving a [__] I know
there's smart people who uh
what's-his-face Muhammad Ali was from
there one of the quickest minds of all
time right anyways proved what
anesthesiologist doctors who oversee the
aura the administration of anesthesia
like we didn't know what the [__] that
was have believed for some time that
redheads are more difficult to knock out
okay as much as that stroking my ego
like we're stronger than you [__]
pigment bastards
how the [__] did they figure that I like
that that they prove what doctors who
administer anesthesia have believed for
some time that it's harder to put
redheads under really you care to tell
some stories of some horrified
freckle-faced people waking up during
the middle of a [__] appendectomy
that I say that right researchers at the
University of Louisville chose 20 test
subject all women all ladies aged 19 to
40 10 were redheads and ten were
brunettes the dark haired subjects were
the control group now he just lost me
what the [__] does that mean you just
said there were 10 redheads 10 were
brunettes the dark-haired subjects were
in the control group I I don't have a
science background what does that mean
the redheads are too wild you can't
control them the research does that mean
that's harder to roofie a redheaded
woman some Persian psycho just sitting
there wondering how money's got a drop
in a [__] drink uh Jesus Christ [__]
you let's plow ahead here we go at all
twenty women were given now who gives a
[__] I can't even read half this stuff
here desflurane a common gas anesthesia
after the anesthesia took effect the
researchers gave each woman electric
shocks Jesus Christ so we in a recession
or what the fact that people would
actually sign up for this would you give
him a Walmart gift card what was the
average amount of teeth of the people in
this 19 to 40 [__] group of women how
many were actually pregnant and you'll
[__] look past it well they're in the
first trimester it's okay
after the anesthesia took effect
electric shocks using a voltage which a
conscious person would have found
intolerable if the subject could feel
the pain the researcher increased the
dosage of desflurane and continue to
administer shocks until they got no
response to the shocks - what year did
they do what was Joe Kennedy around when
they did this did they give somebody a
[__] lobotomy at the end of this the
researchers findings showed that the old
anesthesiologist a dish is adage is true
redheads do require more anesthesia in
fact it took an average of 20% more see
I could have [__] told you that all
those pasty face mix with their [__]
red hair drinking down the pub is all
you [__] Calypso bastards have passed
out underneath the [__] bar
we knew that um anesthesiologist have a
dangerous job and it takes a large
degree of skill to properly put someone
I don't give a [__] about you guys it's
all about me so there you go I can't I
can't tell if I find that a
complimentary story or uh or what I
don't know just like I already felt
weird enough thank you thank you for
sending me that if you guys can send me
more information about redheads that
makes me feel like more of an outsider I
would really appreciate that oh by the
way I actually have Breaking Bad on in
the background on mute I've already seen
this episode because I was lucky enough
to get an advance copy here so but I
have it on mute because I want them to
get credit you know you they only you
only get credit for [__] viewers is
if they watch it live because if you
TiVo it the advertising companies are
like well look when people TiVo [__] my
TiVo shows they just fast-forward
through the commercials so we're not
paying for that so I don't know I don't
know why I decided to tell you that
maybe because it was a way I could all
of a sudden bring up the fact that I'm
gonna be on episode three huh please
watch it this season everybody it's the
best [__] show on TV and you get to
see me for a couple of seconds you know
wouldn't that be nice to put a nice face
to these happy words that are coming
into your [__] ears at this point
alright let's let's plow ahead with the
podcast um all right oh hey by the way I
have gone as of Saturday 9 months with
without booze I'm trying to go a year
people I'm three [__] months away
this is my part am i cleaning up my life
thing alright I've gone nine months with
no booze I've got myself to the point
where I don't [__] lose my temper in
the car anymore you know if you walk
down the sidewalk and you yell at me
you're on your own on that one but and
now I have gone a little over 24 hours
without watching online porn
[Laughter]
so yeah that's the next demon I'm trying
to get out of my life
oh it's gonna be great I'm just gonna go
all the way back gradually go back to
the innocence of who I was when I was a
kid and then what's great is because I'm
an adult and I'm gonna egomaniac I'll
then find Jesus and I'll start preaching
to you guys on this podcast as if I
wasn't a complete piece of [__] for the
last [__] 15 years of my life um yeah
so yeah I'm trying to stop watching
online porn you know I'm gonna try to go
old school I'm gonna try to use the old
fantasies use the old noodle right
little libsyn for you little brain games
hey anybody out there know a good
website that has spelling tests I want
to become a better speller I'm just sick
of being a [__] [__] you know as I
was trying to write jokes this week the
amount of [__] that for the SPS the
amount of [__] people that I can't I
can't [__] the words that I just
cannot spell is beyond me I'm good with
the little ones you know like [__] [__]
you know [__] you can't get on TV but uh
like words like apparently which is a
great word for a monologue joke zabba
Dabba Dabba Dabba Dabba do apparently
yada yada yada right you got to be able
to spell apparently if I'm gonna have
any sort of [__] career
oh Jesus bill I just drove this podcast
right down a [__] alley
I'm sheared off the sideview mirrors is
it gonna be garbage cans blocking it
let's go to this next thing here oh
here's some information Tiger Woods
somebody sent this in Tiger Woods wife
is back in action
Tiger Woods ex lady is back in action
heartbroken Ellen
nor dragon however the [__] you say a
goddamn name heartbroken she's
heartbroken everybody
she got a quarter of a billion dollars
in the divorce settlement and she has
her own Island and she has the [__]
nerve to be heartbroken you know what is
with these broads you know what amazes
me about women
who
marry unbelievable men like Tiger Woods
or Sugar Shane Mosley right men of
unbelievable accomplishment men of
astounding achievement men who are in
the record books what their sense of
[__] entitlement that they have to
the spoils of the pressure that their
husbands dealt with is just [__]
beyond me I get it
Tiger Woods you were married to the lady
you cheated on her she's pissed she
wants to have her [__] you know she
wants to go her separate way she wants
some [__] money but the fact that she
feels she's entitled to that much of the
[__] money and she never had to sink
a putt what do you think would happen to
her if she was standing on the goddamn
wherever the [__] you died don't golf
wherever you tee off the tee off spot
right it's not the green the [__] do you
call that I'll meet you at the the thing
with the little balls there that you tee
off a [__] tee off place can you
imagine if she had to tee off in front
of them not only a millions of [__]
people
you got like 300 people on either side
of the fairway and if you hook or slice
somebody's gonna die she could never
handle that pressure she's worth 250
billion million dollars she's a nanny
she's a [__] nanny and she got half
as much money as Jerry Seinfeld got for
creating and writing the greatest sitcom
of all time her what does she do sit
around a pool French [__]
manicure/pedicure getting your hair
[__] highlighted you know so anyways
evidently she's heartbroken everybody
yeah forget the people in Japan that's
that you know what would they know about
heartbreak you know sure let tsunami
whatever this poor woman do you know I
got to tell you something you know what
it is is most people in Japan they live
in smaller
so I think the problem with is that
Ellen she she has to live in these
gigantic houses by herself so she feels
way more lonely so that's why I think
she's saying she's so much more
heartbroken
so anyways heartbroken Ellen I don't
even know her [__] name because she's
never achieved anything in her life
Nordegren Nadi grin as she's found love
again everybody with wouldn't you know
it a wealthy American investor James
Dingman Ellen who divorced cheating golf
great Tiger Woods you believe that all
the achievement that Tiger Woods all his
accomplishments his first credit now is
cheating
how about greatest golfer of his
generation winner of 14 majors and known
cheater
Tiger Woods following divorcing Tiger
Woods following a series of scandals
with multiple women has dated as has
been dating Dingman and this guy is the
son of a billionaire
Michael Dingman she's been dating him
for months
friends say Jamie is an accomplished
emerging market markets veteran who has
represented his father's interest in
China for the past six years in the mid
90s he specialized in Russian private
equity funds he also owned an IndyCar
racing team sponsored by world childhood
foundation a charity founded by Queen
Silvia of Sweden the charming bachelor
has previously dated bridges Moynahan I
don't know the [__] that is mother of
Tom Brady's baby he was linked last year
to Princess Amanda lean of Sweden see
you know something I don't know if this
Ellen is a genius or if she's a [__]
[__] because if she thinks this guy
isn't gonna cheat on her she's out of
her mind hey Ellen you want a faithful
guy why don't you start with someone who
can't afford a private jet whoo
fly thousands of miles away from your
[__] and your eyeballs why don't you
start with that you know what is your
prerequisite for jumping on a [__] they
have to be a billionaire huh you
gold-digging [__] how come you can't
find love
some guy works in a warehouse I don't
know you know what she's gonna do she's
working her way up you know what zelans
basically doing is she's sucking the
right dicks I gotta tell her that I
gotta tell you that she just this is
genius so Tiger was a billionaire she
[__] walks because he bangs some
[__] chick at a hooters right so she
says all right to hell with you and I'll
take let's see even though we have a
prenup and I'm only entitled to five
million dollars let's work it out and
I'll get a quarter a quarter of a
[__] billion so now she jumps to
another billionaire this this lady she
doesn't even [__] with millionaires so
now she's going to this [__] poor
bastard right she's gonna get her hooks
into him and you know that'll probably
last another six years or whatever then
she's gonna get another 250 right she's
worth half a billion figure at that
point should be able to be like 35 maybe
can she can slide in another [__]
billionaire you know that'll be another
250 she's worth three-quarters of a
[__] billion dollars she invests her
money right she gets 25% on that she's a
billionaire she did it they go ladies
that's how it's done if you're not gonna
choose love that's the way you do it you
know what the greatest thing about all
of it is she'll be painted as a victim
the entire time heartbroken heartbroken
hakama doesn't say heartbroken gold
digger Elin Nordegren Ellen why did you
go [__] yourself my lady
all right um what else do I got this
yeah this is a brutal week for guys
Sugar Shane Mosley's getting a [__]
divorce and his he's got to pay all this
[__] money out all right and his
ex-wife is getting his championship
belts
that's one of them
cruelest things I've ever heard in my
life and she's trying to play it off
going well I'm just keeping him for the
kids and the kids will get him when
they're 18 first of all no you're not
alright that's passive-aggressive
horseshit you're trying to break the guy
that's evil vindictive horseshit for you
to take that and secondly the kids
didn't put their life on the line in the
[__] ring so they don't deserve them
and if they do deserve them it's it
should be [__] Mosley should make the
decision cuz he doesn't want to put his
life on the line you [__] what what
did you do let me guess you supported
him that's that that's your big
entitlement oh my god that's [__]
loud here let's try to have something a
little more sunshiny you know I I try I
encourage women to write in to my
podcast I've been begging you guys for
the like the last six months to a year
at so I can balance this out because I
don't want to keep trashing women it's
just so [__] easy so here we go I got
this woman wrote in thank God a woman
wrote in please write in trash guys I
know we're morons
I need I need balance here this is as
balanced as MSNBC or Fox News I want to
smooth it out here here we go all right
some lady wrote in all right toilet bill
I have a question about men in their
bathroom habits my husband and I have a
great relationship we just celebrated
our fifth wedding anniversary and are
very happy well congratulations
congratulations you have something most
people do not have you have a happy
marriage marriage sorry I get the
hiccups um anyway she said the only
things we ever seem to argue about are
manners and housework we come from
different backgrounds and were raised
differently regarding manners he doesn't
believe he doesn't believe that manners
are important well I do we both had to
adjust to this and it has certainly been
a process my standards for living have
been lowered and his have been raised
we're somewhere in the middle at this
point he has really made an effort over
the years in terms of cleaning up after
himself and not being gross but the one
area that has always been a pro
is the toilet at first he rarely put the
seat down and it drove me crazy he's
wicked smaht he went to havehd and
always philosophizes his way out of
arguments his main argument for leaving
the toilet seat up is that it isn't fair
women and men are equals blah blah blah
he also likes to use the argument that
gay men probably leave the seat up all
the time I'm an interior designer and
have several gay male friends and they
all say they put it down because who
wants to look at the inside of a toilet
the last thing I could say about it was
please just do it as a favor to me he
said he would and I believed him a few
weeks ago I was taking a bath and I left
the door ajar because he worries I'll
drown or something if I lock the door
look at that he's a great guy he's
concerned above you you know there's a
lot of people that could give a [__]
so anyways she's in the bathtub with the
door ajar a little bit he says he
suddenly came in and sat down on the
toilet in front of me and I was stunned
and asked are you pooping and he said no
he was just peeing so now he's pee in a
pees sitting down and insists that this
is normal for men this is where we are
right now in the toilet seat argument he
thinks he's being considerate but really
he's just super stubborn about the
toilet seat he also has no problem of
going to bathroom in front of me and I
wish there was more of a boundary when
it comes to the bathroom in general this
idea has infected my brain so much it
just seems so unmasked Yulin to me to
see a man peeing sitting down that it's
it's now to the point that I think it's
attractive when men pee standing up so
bill what do you think my husband loves
your podcast who listens every morning
yada yeah what do I think he's a great
husband he loves me takes care of me
makes me laugh and he's gorgeous but the
toilet issue weirds me out alright where
to start
first of all this whole toilet issue
this whole tradition that has basically
been started I don't know where it's
began but how if the man
leaves the toilet seat up he's the
biggest [__] [__] on the face of
the earth I don't understand it I don't
understand why we are required to do it
I've never heard a woman
give me a good argument as to why they
say dumb [__] like so I don't fall in
the toilet and it's like that that's my
fault you fell in the toilet who in
their right mind drops their pants and
sits on something without looking at
what they're sitting on do you want to
stand that you're out of your mind
that's on you like why is the toilet
have to be totally set up for you but I
can go [__] myself
how come how come when you're done with
it why can't you lift the seat up if
anything gets more tits easier for you
to put the seat down than for me to put
it up I'm working against gravity you
know and it'd be one thing if you said I
here's one for you if you wanted to put
the seat down because this is what's
really going on you've nagged him enough
and it's annoying him that he has to put
the [__] seat down all right so now
what he's doing is what he's he's
actually he's brilliant he knows that
peeing sitting down is weirding you out
well he's doing this passive-aggressive
[__] where he's like all right you want
the seat down fine
I'm gonna I'm gonna start peeing sitting
down like a woman and make it all
[__] weird for you and then I'm gonna
act like that oh that's more efficient I
like it I'm enjoying this [__] he's he's
playing the only card he has I think
it's [__] hilarious this is my advice
to you if you want him to go back to
peeing standing up and putting the seat
down basically your dream bathroom
situation why don't you give up
something why don't you say okay if you
do that for me I will do this you know
why don't you say like look if you go a
month straight you know and and always
put the seat down after 30 days I will
give you the most insane [__] you've
ever had in your life okay
why don't you do something okay instead
of acting like you'reyou're you're
[__] some sort of royalty and that
everything should just be set up for you
all right I agree with you that's
[__] weird it's weird for me to
picture him sitting down but I think
he's doing it in this passive aggressive
way which is [__] hilarious to me all
right there you go that's what I would
say blow him once a month as long as he
keeps the seat down that's my solution
all right and God bless you and
congratulations on your good
relationship all right moving on mate
bill I was just watching the news and
saw this lady who cut off her husband's
dick and then threw it into the garbage
disposal turning it on as she did so why
is this behaviour shown in women lemme
see why is this show why is this
behavior shown in women I mean a guy
would have just left her wife but women
have to set your stuff on fire cut up
your car with keys if you're in an
argument with them if they don't like
what you say they turn into a banshee
and start slapping and cursing you out
many decent guys have to sit there and
take this [__] take it until they have
had enough and the female can't I'm
sorry guys I'm really butchering this oh
this no it's how this guy wrote it unn
still that's not even a word dude let me
just try to plow through this they
hadn't until the guys had enough and the
female can't take this [__] anymore
that's when [__] like cutting off dicks
setting his [__] on fire scarring up
your car and slashing the wheels in your
car come into play do they think this is
normal [__] to do and yes I know a lot
of women would never do these things but
they would agree at their little [__]
pal meetings going honey chill she did
the right thing
uh-huh [__] persons writing dialogue
for me yeah well I mean they're held to
a different set of standards both good
and bad you know they're held to a
different set of standards as far as sex
goes they go out and did have to
you did their [__] you're a stud and
when it comes to stuff like this yeah
they get away with it
I don't know why I don't know why they
do stuff like that they are very I don't
know I have no idea I mean I think
you're hard-pressed to find a guy who
hasn't had his [__] attacked by a woman
you know I mean obviously if a woman
cheated on me I would be upset I'd
scream at her I call her a bunch of
names call her a [__] [__] but I
would never think to destroy her car or
throw all our hooker where out onto the
[__] yard and set it on fire you know
why we can't do that [__] because when I
when a guy goes ape [__] like that they
call the cops and we get arrested dude
if you call the cops and they show up in
your wardrobes on fire they're gonna
have all they can do to not start
laughing cuz they know why she did it
cuz you [__] around and they're both
dead dirtbags too so they're all going
like you got caught didn't you it's like
that guy thing we just [__] laugh
it's no solidarity amongst guys we just
we [__] laugh I think that's why it
is but um you know I'm gonna go out on a
limb here most women aren't gonna cut
your dick off and throw it in the
garbage disposal you know that that
woman is a [__] maniac
and you you wait I I can't wait to see
that trial to see what she gets you know
she's gonna get off she'll get off
somehow just be like it was a crime of
passion she was a little bit crazy oh my
god she's just a girl she'll probably do
like six months all right let's go -
overrated underrated for this week I got
to wrap this podcast up because I'm
trying to get this thing up before
midnight and tomorrow's a travel day for
me
overrated underrated for this week these
are great by the way overrated nurses
I'm going to be careful on this I have
some friends who are nurses here my wife
and I just had our first baby and she
was in labor for a day and a half day
and a half and labor god bless her I
noticed as we went through about four
ships of nurse
is that every single one of them at some
point managed to cram in how difficult
their job was and how they're underpaid
have to work long hours and don't get
any respect my wife is an excruciating
pain and I haven't slept for two days so
perhaps you feeling the need to nail
yourself to a cross every time you carry
your bloated ass down the hall to dole
out an aspirin is falling on deaf ears
and tases we were right outside the
nursing pen when those hogs sat around
[Laughter]
those hogs but a great word sat around
the whole night cackling at [__] jokes
and knocking down Krispy Kremes as they
patted each other on the back granted I
would have blown my brains out if I was
stuck on the graveyard shift with that
herd all night can we give this guy a
round of applause for the amount of
different creative ways he's been able
to call these women fat bloated hogs and
herd you have a future in writing my
friend anyways I'd blow my brains out if
I was stuck on the graveyard shift with
that herd all night but it didn't
exactly seem like the toughest job in
the world what really killed me is how
they would go on to [__] about the
doctors and how they will all at how the
doctors were all arrogant and don't know
anything I really felt like telling them
I get that both you and the doctor have
papers hanging on the wall but the
difference is that his are medical
degrees from Stanford and Princeton and
yours is an honorable mention from a
community college and his ziggy cartoon
from 1989 let's just say MD gets the tie
and move on what makes them overrated
here we go let's get to the point is
that you can't call them out on their
[__] because although they don't do
much they can make your life miserable
while you're there so instead of going
off on them I sent my dad out to refill
their slop bucket with a couple dozen
chocolate glazed underrated doctors I
know they get respect already but they
deserve more No
saturation we spoke with the doctor for
10 minutes she came in looked at our
charts did some stuff on a few machine
machines then laid out three choices and
recommended one 45 minutes later we had
a healthy baby girl um dude that's
[__] hilarious but I got to defend
nurses and they do work their asses off
in that type of [__] but uh I think a
lot of it was your emotional but you you
are making some point now if they're
sitting out there cackling about [__]
jokes eating doughnuts then Jesus Christ
did you deliver your [__] baby and
I'm in a precinct that sounds like a
bunch of cop jokes to me
all right there we go overrated hey this
ties into the other one peeing standing
up is overrated
it's a real pleasure in the middle of
the night to leave the lights off and
pee sitting down even during the day and
you just want to sit down for a minute
sitting down while peeing is awesome
what is going on with the [__] men of
this generation they need to [__]
thank God Oprah went off the air maybe
we can [__] Jesus Christ something
there's another thing if I was [__]
president I would I would get one of
those old b-52 bombers and I would spray
cities with like male cologne so I'm
sort of germ warfare to make guys a
little more [__] I don't know what
happened to us we did great right up
until the 80s all those Hardcastle and
mcCormick ridiculous testosterone shows
or everybody had like a [__] cool car
and they were banging a bunch of women
hairy chests and a [__] medallion
what happened to those days everybody's
awkward now acting like you're 14 on a
first [__] date I can't relate to
anybody on TV anymore anyways underrated
jerking off to non pornographic material
oh this will help me out uh I almost
find it more enjoyable to jerk off to
someone to some off to a thought of some
girl I saw us
door or to jerk off to some random girl
I saw on TV and then he loses all
confidence like he's a freak and starts
yelling at me don't eat don't you even
dare say you've never done this burr I
know you go back to your hotel room
after a show and jerk off to that big
titted [__] in the front row hey dude
listen if this is what you want to do
stand by it don't try to drag me into
your [__] world I'm actually right
there with you [__] yelling at me
overrated going to the beach or or
boardwalk guess what it's the exact same
as it was the last 50 times you were
here but more expensive with more
[__] isn't that the truth underrated
trips to another city is underrated
there's always awesome [__] going on in
every city up and down the East Coast
that you haven't done to death
catch a game at Camden Yards check out
one of the dozens of free museums in DC
you haven't gone to since the eighth
grade you need a cheesesteak where they
sign the Constitution see a random show
at the Comedy Cellar walk the Freedom
Trail actually don't watch block the
Freedom Trail visit Sam Adams instead
that was a good one
underrated going into going into work
hungover you being this guy's like this
is this is amazing
cuz I don't think I could do this he
says go in dope going into work hungover
is underrated you'd be amazed at what
you can accomplish with half a
functioning brain in a bad attitude I'm
one of those people that under normal
circumstances would lose his dick if it
wasn't velcro Don but when I'm hungover
and at work I can get done in three
hours what usually takes me three days
maybe it's that I subconsciously don't
give a [__] and want to go back to bed
but I swear I always drink like a sailor
the night before I have to do a big
project or go to a big meeting that's a
new one dude if it works for you last
one overrated trying to bang girls you
work with I've tried this twice one time
it ended with me putting my hand into a
telephone pole out of frustration from
being a minute
from her being a manipulative [__] yeah
but dude you took the bait you took the
bait I'll get back to it let me I'll
finish reading this seriously most girls
who will come across as easy at the
office oftentimes are filthy [__] who
end up [__] a traveling soccer team
and then all you hear about at work is
how they have crabs and their pisses
greened instead of banging girls at work
I'll stick to low self-esteem girls who
go to Starbucks and movies alone do that
thing when you punch the telephone pole
I hope I hope you learned something from
that one because you're you're making
yourself the victim there
these manipulative [__] you're giving
them all the power just know that they
manipulating you don't allow it to
happen all right
figure it out don't lose your temper
like me and scream I'm on the phone
all right advice and then this will be
the end of it uh hey Bill I need some
advice on picking up this chick I saw
her a few weeks ago at the gym and she
has huge fake boobs I've never grabbed
huge fake boobs
I want to grab huge fake boobs she's
always wearing really small low-cut
shirts of course she is she got she
wants to show off what she's got now
whenever I see her I get home and I have
to jerk off and not mild jerking off
I mean double-handed [__] it looks like
I'm giving myself the Heimlich but my
dick is in the way see ladies this is
why I want you to write in because this
is getting really [__] blue this is
like the ninth conversation about
jerking off and I know you're all
sitting there with your nose wrinkled up
and your brow furrowed what do something
about it see this is what I need Nia to
come in and [__] rescue the podcast
like she did last week but I'm on the
road so there's nothing I can do I got
to plow through this so anyways he said
today I finally talked to her at the old
drinking fountain this is the fake
titted [__] here we're chatting about
how people didn't work really hard at
the gym and I complimented her on how
hard she works out then he says yeah I
know it's cheesy [__] you Birds true and
I had to say something
why is everybody coming at me
I didn't say it was cheesy you [__]
lost confidence in it
so anyways he said when I told her when
I when I told her it
oh the compliment she tilted her head
and said ah well it well thanks no Jesus
that's so that's like one of the worst
responses you can get she said it as if
I was a five-year-old giving her a
flower she some of you guys really ought
to start doing stand-up these have like
a ridiculous level of funny these last
couple here man are really written well
she looks like she's probably older
maybe mid 30s while I'm 22 no Jesus okay
during our conversation she said that
she was so tired from the weekend so I'm
guessing she might be a partier very
good police work I'm not saying you're
right but I like I like the way you're
thinking you're trying to put the pieces
together
I don't really party but I'll smoke
crack sniff coke and shoot heroin into
my eyes as long as I can play with those
little baby toes glued to the end of
those watermelons she calls boobs
yeah that's disgusting uh I'm not sure
if she is single or not the proof I have
that she's single she has no wedding
ring but we're at the gym so she may
have taken it off proof that she isn't
single her titties are the size of
kelsey Grammer's head help me grab them
titties for a night bill all right
[Music]
okay here we go
where do I start with this one okay so
you're going after I need a little more
information is this okay so she's
obviously the girl with the big [__]
fake tits she's wearing all those tight
outfits you know and she's probably
going into the weightlifting room
bending over and doing all that [__]
does she also wear a lot of makeup when
she works out I think if she wore a ton
of makeup when she worked out she
actually might have talked to you for
half a second because that would have
been a whole nother level of low
self-esteem but
[Music]
I don't know dude this this is this is a
hard one
because you're a lot younger than she is
she already gave me the uh well thanks
so obviously complimenting her is not
the way to go I think you gotta [__]
just sort of strike up current now that
you talk to her just get into it this is
what I would do get into a whole [__]
every time you see her you say what's up
to her talk to her a little bit but you
got to have that I don't give a [__]
attitude I don't know dude
I might have [__] I don't know I see
this is one I might need me on this one
alright you know what you know what is
because I'm using your jump off point
where you already said like I really
like you know you work out really hard
you know then she goes off see right
there when she said ah well thanks I
would have said ah jeez alright I blew
it on that one I need to adjust it so
what the [__] would I do
how the [__] that life I don't know what
what the [__] would I do that's a heart
I never did well with those kinds of
girls that I think this is why it's
[__] me up I'm trying to blame you
but I never did well with those those
girls like that big fake [__] tits
just screaming for attention I never did
well with them so and I gotta tell you
dude you know what's overrated big fake
tits they're fun to look at but it's not
like when you touch them you can feel
the [__] bag in there at least the
last time I did it the last time I
touched a fair of para fair fake takes a
pair of fake tits was probably Jesus a
long time ago maybe like ten years ago
actually touched them but they've come
up to me like when I'm in Dallas and
they press up against you you know gonna
taking pictures after the show that did
dude they have something alien in their
[__] tits it's it's and I tell you
they only look good when they're covered
up when they take them off to just
standing there staring at you it's weird
titties shouldn't have a circle at the
top they should [__] hang down they
should be fun you know and move with the
they should be sitting there looking at
you like that judging you I don't know
dude I don't know I need more your
background I got to know what your
background what did you got anything
going on in your life anything you could
invite her to like I have nothing but
that the normal [__] make her laugh and
then steer the conversation towards sex
I really I don't I don't know how to
approach a [__] woman like that
goddamnit you stumped if the [__] uh
I had diarrhea the mouth you absolutely
stumped me I have no [__] idea I have
no idea but take this into consideration
there's a bunch of big tinted [__] out
there alright so you struck out with
that one I don't I don't know what to
tell you
can I can I say that for another ten
minutes I got nothing hour and five
minutes in alright YouTube videos for
the week
you know what [__] why don't you go
right up and ask her start talking about
her tits you know just go up and be rude
put your gym membership on the line and
just walk right up a how's it going just
next time she comes walking around the
corner with her big tits just react to
him Jesus Christ you [__] you trying
to hurt somebody with those things
whatever just get it going that get her
giggling laugh and I would just go down
that just no respect no respect for this
woman with no respect for any sort of
sexual harassment or anything [__] you
and your big fake tits they're right
there they're in my face and I'm talking
about them alright I got an angle I
don't know if it's gonna work but that's
what I would do next time next time
something like that Jesus Christ with
your big tits
you serious excuse me what yeah big tits
the [__] [__] got to go home and jerk
off every time can you wear a how about
a hoodie every once in a while there you
go there you go [__] that jerking off
part you'll creeper oh go that angle
address how big her [__] titties are
and then just act like you're
overwhelmed can you put a sweatshirt on
I'm having difficult [__] working out
maybe go that route this is like writing
monologue jokes I'm just throwing [__]
against the wall trying to find
something funny start with that alright
[__] her and a big goddamn tits this is
what I would do if I was you rub one out
before you go to the gym all right see
your balls aren't full you know telling
you dumb [__] in your head see you balls
are empty you're thinking [__]
clearly all right you know what it is
her tits I like the bully at school
they're bullying you right now and
you're getting in your [__] head and
I'm in my head and I have you know what
this [__] looks like alright so I think
it's time you stood up to the bow the
bully call her out call her out on a big
fake [__] tits in her little outfit
she knows what she's doing then I come
up and I compliment you and you give me
all thanks
you should have [__] did you see that
[__] punch Ortiz threw when he missed
the Orioles pitcher where it wasn't a
hook and it wasn't an uppercut it sort
of looked like a Kentico v side armpit
that's all you should have slapped her
[__] tits come in a [__] 35 degree
angle I'm sorry brother I got nothing I
really if anybody has if anybody has an
angle if you can help this guy out man
down man down
all right we need to help this guy out
this with this podcast about making you
laugh on Monday helping you out your
personal lives this kid wants to touch
some fake titties I got nothing
help him out alright YouTube videos of
the week you got to go to the mmm
podcast you got to go to the mmm podcast
calm we got all these lined up these are
the funniest goddamn what we've had in a
while these are fantastic so you don't
have to go to youtube and search all of
these you just got to sit there and what
you can just you know blow right through
them and you [__] cubicle act like
you're working doing market research
whatever the [__] you supposed to be
doing alright YouTube video of the week
Frankie and Johnny it's this furniture
store and this is one of the greatest
commercials I've ever seen in my life
you know like when a local store they
can't afford professionals so they'd
have the
please do the commercial this is what
they did and these people are [__]
brilliant
jet pack fail I know a lot of people saw
this or saw it already I actually
watched it on the Jimmy Fallon show it's
awesome
Wilde caddy you got to see this this is
actually a 59 for you guys
gear heads out there it's a 59 Cadillac
two-door with the giant tail fins that
somebody tricked out down in Australia
and the really interesting thing about
this car is because it's in Australia
it's I've never seen it it's a 59
Cadillac with the steering on a steering
wheel on the right hand side it's
[__] it's insane and the console in
the middle is a replica the tail fins on
the back of the car this car has I don't
know it's got to be it's definitely two
hundred thousand dollar car the amount
of money this guy put it in the car it's
[__] insane there's another great one
restaurant owner bans kids it's a local
news story this guy he just bandaged
under six six years of age because they
make too much [__] noise and the guy
he's unapologetic all these moms are
complaining goes now you know I don't I
don't I understand that it's your kid
and it's the center of your universe but
it's not the center of our universe
basically said go [__] yourselves it was
great to see somebody stand up against
the backlash [__] you they make too much
noise why you bring them to this
restaurant [__] sitting there with
apple sauce in their hair they don't
even appreciate what the [__] were
cooking here these people are like well
we always go here I don't know where
else to take my kid take on with
chuck-e-cheese take him to McDonald's
why don't you make him a [__] peanut
butter jelly sandwich if you're
concerned about his health no here's a
great one Sox fan grabs a boob during a
Red Sox game I got this one from Opie on
Opie and Anthony it's just [__] great
they cut into a couple of fans and then
you know they go out look at those two
nice couples and the guy just reaches
over and grabs his girl's titty
and Jerry Remy [__] loses it it's it's
just [__] hilarious
and then George Michael saxophone guy
phenomenal just this guy playing the
saxophone I you could just go look at
him I can't describe why the funny and
here's another one I want to add Bobby
Kelly's scared Opie from the Opie and
Anthony show it's just [__] awesome
the noise Opie makes is hilarious we're
gonna have that video up there and then
there's another video where Opie and Joe
DeRosa Joe DeRosa the teen Isle
sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program try to scare Bobby Kelly and
they they completely botched the job and
both of those clips and if you're online
listen to the Opie and Anthony show get
an XM Player I don't have any of the
[__] information but it's the best
radio show for my money out there and
before I leave and wrap up the podcast I
want to thank everybody who's been
making a you know the generous donations
we have a donation button on the mmm
podcast calm it helps me pay my web guy
it helps me to reinvest you know all
that type of [__] else gives me some
walking-around money when I'm in Santos
a thank you to everybody who's clicked
in I'm really blown away by all the
donations that I've got and that is it
that's the podcast for this week
everybody have a great week please watch
Breaking Bad again next week
it's on 10 o'clock on AMC if you can I
know you guys are busy but if you can
watch it live it just helps their
ratings not that they need help but uh
why not why not have some more people on
it like I said I believe I'm in episode
3 possibly episode 2 I don't know I
think it's episode 3 and I'm beyond
excited to be a part of that and once
again thanks to Seth Meyers and
everybody at the SBS for letting me and
Paul virzi submit our jokes and actually
doing our jokes it was a big thrill for
both of us that's the podcast for this
week go [__] yourselves I'll talk to you
next week and how about those Pittsburgh
Pirates how about I almost forgot how
about the first place Pittsburgh Pirates
it's 1979 all over it
again now if the [__] Orioles could
just catch the Red Sox to the Yankees
that's my dream world series it's my
dream world series I want to see the
Pittsburgh Pirates and the Orioles have
a rematch and I want the Pirates to go
back to those yellow on yellow with the
yellow [__] hats Kentico vie to throw
out the first pitch maybe John
Candelaria over the [__] you say his
name the Candyman back when baseball was
great all right that's the podcast I'll
talk to you next
[Music]
[Applause]